catherine flavie ni lé maire de mont
saint-aignan en seine maritime
bonjour je lisais un instant il ya donc
deux unités de production qui sont
désormais autorisés à reprendre et c'est
le conseil départemental de
l'environnement et des risques
sanitaires et technologiques qui a été
favorable à cela
est ce que vous le comprenez eh bien
écoutez oui je le comprends tout à fait
bien sûr il faut ré ouvrir ces deux
unités avec toutes les garanties que
nous devons à l'environnement à de nos
concitoyens en particulier mais je suis
évidemment favorable au fait que l'on
puisse réouvrir ces deux unités et est
favorable au fait que l'on puisse lutter
sous toutes ses formes lutter contre la
désindustrialisation de notre territoire
et pour maintenir les emplois de notre
territoire
je ne le vois pas comment on pourrait
faire autrement si on fait l'impasse sur
des entreprises aussi importante que
celle que peut jouer aussi
lubrizol sur notre territoire
justement vous parlez d'emploi
d'économie certains pensent justement
que la priorité économique mais un peu
en danger la vie des salariés et de la
population
mais écoutez ça c'est une affaire enfin
je veux dire on ne peut pas réouvrir
bien entendu n'importe comment mais je
pense qu'il est nécessaire de se couvrir
bien sûr et de prendre des garanties
mais ceci est faisable
il faut savoir à un moment donné si on
veut tout de même protégé sur notre
territoire les emplois en prenant toutes
les précautions voulues ou si on ne le
veut pas moi je suis favorable au fait
que vraiment lubrizol puis ré ouvrir
dans les meilleures conditions possibles
et je pense qu'on est aussi capable de
pouvoir garantir ces conditions là
donc pour vous donner les moyens donc
pour vous contrairement à ce qui a été
dit par certains élus cette réouverture
de la deuxième unité de production
ce n'est pas trop rapide et ce n'est pas
précipités au contraire c'est opportun à
ce moment écoutez je crois qu'on vit en
plus avec lakovic 19
une période qui économiquement on va
être extrêmement difficile à la rentrée
je ne pense pas que quelqu'un puisse
aujourd'hui le contraire alors je crois
que justement la réouverture est à
propos pour essayer de protéger des
emplois que nous avons la chance il faut
bien le dire comme cela d'avoir sur
notre territoire
donc prenons les moyens garantissons les
choses pour que lubrizol puisse rouvrir
réouvrir dans des bonnes conditions mais
permettons que les emplois d'autres
régions puissent être protégées ça me
semble vraiment important aussi
alors le nettoyage oui encore en cours
et manifestement certains riverains se
sont plaints d'une odeur nauséabonde et
hydrocarbures de maux de gorge des
nausées
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez oui
alors bien sûr il ya certainement encore
des conséquences ne sont pas enfin qui
sont encore que l'on peut respirer par
exemple mais vous savez les odeurs c'est
parce qu'il y à n'en plus de pie ix
je prends aussi toutes les précautions
oratoires dans les mots que j'utilise
c'est pas parce qu'on sent quelque chose
que cette chose sera fatalement la plus
nocive possible je pense qu'il faut
prendre les précautions comme je voulais
10 pour faire que le site soit nettoyé
dans l'est dans les meilleures
conditions et qu'on puisse améliorer
tout cela assez rapidement mais il faut
penser aux conséquences que cela a sur
l'emploi et je pense que ça c'est
vraiment une chose primordiale
voilà catherine flamini merci vous êtes
mer et l'air de mont-saint-aignan seine
maritime
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur arte france